you can kiss the america first agenda
goodbye it's now windmills solar panels
and china eating our lunch
president biden is in england this week
on his self-proclaimed america is back
tour
he's set to meet with top allies at the
g7 on ways to counter challenges
and threats from china and russia our
top general issued a warning about
today about beijing's increased military
capabilities and the fbi director says
cyber attacks pose a serious threat
while american companies are facing a
barrage
of hacks coming from russia but the
president claims
this is what we should be worried about
when i first
was elected vice president with
president obama
the military sat us down to let us know
what the greatest threats facing america
were the greatest physical threats
this is not a joke you know what the
joint chiefs told us the greatest threat
facing america was
global warming the only reason he said
this is not a joke
because even he knew it was a joke
to state the obvious global warming
can't unleash bio terror shut down your
grid tamper with your food supply or fly
planes into buildings
of course biden said something
completely different when he was running
for president
i think the biggest threat to america
right now in terms of breaking up our
our security and our alliances is russia
what happened to that guy maybe global
warming fried his brain
dana while you were listening to that
tape what did you say to me i said this
is offensive
yeah you said it was offensive and you
said it with a guttural growl
you should hear it yeah it's pretty easy
it is pretty amazing and also thank you
for pointing out my real estate license
apparently like people have taken this
very seriously and i'm being asked
to lay out what my goals are it's great
to have a backup career dana you never
know
this show has only been going for nine
and a half years it would be five weeks
yes here we are but you never know this
is true okay so
yeah existential threat there are people
who will say that
climate change the number one issue on
their and their their biggest worry and
i know that the military
takes the issue seriously however we
also are dealing with the fact that um
what it's like everybody knows that
we're in a cold war a second cold war
with china
but nobody's really acting accordingly
yeah um and
and i would put that to climate change
if china is building a coal-fired power
plant a week
then if the global climate change issue
is a global issue
yeah it doesn't matter you could can i
say that p-i-s-s-i-n-g
in the wind yes yeah pissing in the wind
that's basically what you're doing
yes we're going to take your legs let's
have the eu and the united states and
canada and australia trying to reduce
emissions if they're increasing
emissions then it doesn't matter
yeah so um i felt like that was a little
offensive
not as defensive as using that language
but i'm sure the children at home are
very happy to learn how to spell a
filthy word
jesse how stupid do you have to be to
say
right after a pandemic caused by an
engineered virus
that climate change is the number one
threat you have to be pretty stupid greg
yes are you calling the president stupid
i would never do such a thing i'll leave
it to me
i usually when i think threats i think
of death and money so
climate change has killed how many
people zero the china virus killed
six hundred thousand in this country
alone you add the fentanyl that they
bring over to mexico
the cartels pushed that up here hundreds
of thousands of fentanyl
deaths here what islamic terror you
count the overseas wars you're talking
tens of thousands of american lives
lost russian hacking tens of millions of
dollars maybe over a hundred millions of
dollars
so yeah it's not a joke i mean no one's
laughing except we
are at joe biden maybe they did tell him
that and if they did tell him that they
should be fired but i don't think they
even said that
i think joe just doesn't even remember a
defense department official has never
said ever
and i looked i had johnny look publicly
that
that climate change is the number one
threat actually joint chiefs chairman
mark milley just had to come out
and clarify that china and russia are
the top threats
but maybe during the obama
administration they thought that climate
change was the top threat that would
explain how they missed isis
yeah and how they got how the russians
and the chinese hacked us to death
but i think joe tries to elevate the
threat of climate change to distract
from the real problems that he's
bungling
right like the cartels like the cyber
terrorists and like china and russia
so it's just kind of a deflection um and
and it's kind of it's weird it's weird
because he can't keep track of all the
threats that he's listed last time it
was white supremacy
they should combine the two i was
thinking about that combined white
supremacy with
climate change call it uh what do you
call it white
white weather white weather yes very
dangerous global whiteness
global whiteness jessica you were
scowling at me
because you find that offensive i you
can believe that climate change is an
issue
but still see this as absurd because
climate change you you
people are working on it you can work on
it over time but it does not
intentionally con i mean it's not an
intentional and immediate threat
so that's i think that's the problem
when sensible people hear this they're
going like
no they're not climate change isn't
trying to kill us
over a hundred years an incremental
increase in celsius could be an issue
so i think that you can obviously pack
climate change into this larger
discussion of threats obviously and i
did think that joe biden was right on
the campaign trail
to call out russia specifically and to
have tough talk about china and we all
remember barack obama when he was
debating mitt romney said you know
like the 80s called and they'd like
their foreign policy back etc
but there are people today in our
country and all across the world
who do wake up completely frightened of
climate change they're people who are in
the way
of flash floods people who have been
wiped out from hurricanes and we spend
billions and billions of dollars here
through fema and other organizations to
rebuild cities like houston
to rebuild florida after don't look at
me like that jesse it's true
i'm just trying not to interrupt because
that has nothing to do with climate
change of course it does no it doesn't
no even the government data refutes that
the government data by pro climate
change people say that extreme weather
is not correlated with right now
actually that's true about hurricanes
greg's right yeah it's i mean it's it's
like it's in there and
even though even the brush fires are
declining over time compared to say 100
years ago
i don't mean to poke a hole in your
theory but i do
i'm thrilled for you to do it and i'm
sticking to my guns on this one actually
because i'm going to pull up state
department reports that have come out
under the obama administration and the
trump administration where mike pompeo
who didn't want to have to admit it had
to say yes refugees
was a civil war i i understand that and
assad is a very bad dude i'm not
refuting any of that but
climate does play a part in how we see
migration
about this big yeah i don't think it's i
don't think it's in the top
seven kennedy uh what do you what's your
take on this
you're pro science i i i love science
you know what
actually i'm going after you kennedy is
going after science
that's that's i've always said it uh no
one believes me maybe it's because i
lack
a degree in anything scientific but
dana's absolutely right it's all about
china
and i think some of the statements that
president biden has made in the past
about china are going to come back and
bite him because he's like china's not
going to eat our lunch
it's global warming and that's what vice
president harris said when she went to
guatemala
she said we want to make guatemala great
again and the reason you guys are
leaving you guys
is because climate change meanwhile uh
they're growing
all sorts of drugs and having them land
in plains in the jungles of guatemala
the drug war is a much bigger driver for
people
leaving the northern triangle than
climate change ever will be it's not
high up on people's lists like people
don't walk around going i'm just so
worried about the climate i have to get
to the u.s
that's that's not what's happening but
when i saw that statement that the
president made the only thing i could
picture
were uh presidents g and putin on the
phone together just
laughing hysterically going oh my god
and then i went one step further
and thought maybe joe biden is like
kaiser so say like maybe he's pretending
to be this complete dullard but secretly
he's a villain and he just wants to
completely lower
people's expectations of him and then uh
he's going to go there's one other one
there's one other reason they do it
biden did it and then last week putin
did he said climate change big important
issue
you get adoring media coverage yeah it's
a it's so
easy to do oh maybe i should start
pushing climate change give it a shot it
helps
you it's not going to help wait until
your book comes out i'm long gone
it's like the equivalent of like posting
thirsty pictures on instagram
the political equivalent and way to
spoil the
finale of all the usual suspects
i didn't say who it was yeah just duller
that's probably one of the best movies
ever was that
was it kevin spacey hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else